[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'entretien politique
avec comme invités arthur de haine
bonjour jean patrice vous êtes
conseiller municipal de maisons laffitte
dont le mérite jacques billard je
rappelle vous êtes ancien élève de l'ena
enseigne à sciences po
vous êtes le fondateur aussi de
l'association l'équipe et qui tente de
corriger des inégalités sociales pour
favoriser l'accès à la réussite scolaire
et sociale des jeunes les plus
défavorisés
mais c'est d'autre chose que nous allons
parler aujourd'hui vous allez nous
parler du référendum annoncé par le
président de la république référendum
qui prévoit d'introduire cette phrase
dans la constitution la république
garantit la préservation de la
biodiversité de l'environnement et lutte
contre les dérèglements climatiques
référendum auquel vous avez consacré une
tribune qui est paru dans marianne
alors d'abord première question pourquoi
ce serait un homme vous paraît-il
nécessaire alors qu'il existe déjà une
charte de l'environnement depuis 2005
charte qui a valeur constitutionnelle
est ce que est ce que ce n'est pas au
fond une redite alors de ce point de vue
là oui c'est une redite
c'est à dire que ce que je valide dans
la proche gouvernemental c'est le
principe du référendum sur la question
écologique parce que le référendum c'est
un acte qui est à la fois souverain et
populaire et je crois qu'en matière
écologique justement on a besoin d'une
grande option souveraine et populaire je
veux dire par là que on a fait depuis 30
ans le choix d'une option qui est celle
de la mondialisation du libre échange
qui a été il faut le dire il faut le
dire validé par les français par un
référendum en 1992 et que sinon nous
souhaitions revenir sur quelque chose
revenir ou en tout cas proposé quelque
chose qui serait un modèle de production
sur le sol français sur le sol européen
je pense que le référendum est un geste
politique de nature à nous donner
les langues nous avons besoin pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
donc pour répondre directement à votre
question je pense que un référendum sur
un morceau de phrase n'a pas d'intérêt
n'a pas de sens le référendum c'est une
bonne chose s'il permet d'impulser un
changement de modèle
alors justement vous avez déjà abordé
quelques idées des problématiques que
pose d'ailleurs votre tribune vous
écrivez de dire que ce référendum est
une bonne idée à condition de remettre
en cause vous venez de le dire
la modélisation je vous cite qui depuis
40 ans à mener tant de caste politique
sociale et écologique valeur lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
ça ne peut être que mondiale comment on
peut être à la fois contractualisation
et voilà une lutte mondiale parce que si
on est tout seul à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique on n'y arrivera
pas alors oui effectivement
cela étant le modèle sur lequel repose
notre notre environnement économique
c'est à la fois le modèle européen
l'europe c'est 8 à 10% des émissions de
co2 donc il ya un travail qui peut être
fait au niveau européen et au niveau
mondial comme vous dites et là ça
suppose de revoir les règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
mais si on a une coalition européenne
puissante sur ce sujet là et qui en fait
part du principe que nous recalons
localisons c'est à dire que nous faisons
produire en europe des choses qui
aujourd'hui sont produites dans des
conditions écologiques dramatique
singulièrement en chine et aux états
unis qui a eu deux totalisent
pratiquement la moitié des émissions de
co2 de la planète
tout simplement parce que ils produisent
avec du charbon ils produisent avec du
gaz alors que par exemple en france où
capitalise énormément sur l'énergie
nucléaire
vous voyez c'est notamment en recentrant
comme ça au niveau européen on arrivera
à changer une dynamique qui nous
fragilise justement au niveau mondial ça
n'a pas de sens si vous voulez
d'organiser une grand messe mondiale à
l'assemblée générale des nations-unies
ça n'aboutira à rien je crois qu'il faut
assumer que l'europe peut être porteuse
d'un modèle de production plus vert et
s'engager résolument par le
protectionnisme écologique et sociale
dans une bataille pour que la part de ce
qui est produit dans le monde le soit
avec dernier des énergies propres en
europe et pas avec des énergies sales
allions dire vous défendez ce que vous
appelez la souveraineté et que le vix
vous vous dites l'arc allure à leur
localisation d'un certain nombre
d'industries non seulement ça va créer
des emplois mais évidemment ça évite
d'un importés de pays très lointain oui
cela étant il ya une chose quand même
qu'il faut que je tiens à préciser sur
ce concept de souveraineté écologique
c'est à dire que le protectionnisme peut
bien avoir en tête que ce sont des taxes
qui certes pèsent sur les producteurs
étrangers et un moteur européen donc là
où il faut pas qu'on soit amnésique
c'est qu'il faut pas qu'on fasse la même
erreur qu'avec les gilet jaune
c'est pour ça que je parle d'écologie
souveraine est populaire c'est à dire
que si demain on crée une taxe
il faut forcer dans le produit de cette
taxe quelle qu'elle soit soit resservi
aux ménages qui en ont besoin
il ya eu par exemple vous l'avez vu
patrice 7 ce chèque donner aux plus
démunis pour l'achat de bio et l'achat
en circuit court
ça c'est une très bonne chose c'est une
très bonne chose si on a une écologie
que par la fiscalité par la taxe ça ne
marchera pas il faut que le produit de
la taxe soir servi aux ménages que l'on
besoin parce que faut que ça soit une
écologie du pouvoir d'achat reste ici
non on est perdu vous parliez tout à
l'heure de dire et faire de 2,92 sébaste
ricin et vous de vous prônez d'ailleurs
le changement d'un certain nombre de
traités européens
on dira faut il faut que l'europe se
dote de grands champions notamment de
guy traut l'hydrogène des transports de
l'énergie voulait lutter contre quoi
contre le fait que l'europe empêche
justement cette réunion ii d'avoir des
hauts fonds d'aidé des grandes grandes
grandes entreprises exactement
il ya un an de cela
le ministre de l'économie bono le maire
est le ministre de l'économie et des
finances allemand monsieur olaf scholz
avait écrit ensemble juste après vous
savez le rejet de la fusion alstom
siemens pour favoriser les grands
champions européens
moi je crois qu'on ne s'en sortira que
comme ça et aujourd'hui les règles de
concurrence européennes nous pénalise
fortement nous met en difficulté nous
empêche d'avoir la taille critique qui
nous faut pour justement pour réduire de
manière complètement souveraine sur le
sol européen
le fait que alstom pour conclure un
pacte avec bombardier soit obligé
d'abandonner une usine à reichshoffen
c'est pas normal si vous voulez c'est
pas normal et il faut mettre un terme à
ça parce que si on abandonne des usines
sur le sol français
elles seront remplacées par des usines
n'ont pas forcément normes et à
l'étranger et singulièrement en chine
est fait à produire une rame de train
avec de l'électricité issue du charbon
et du gars sympa le même impact que
lorsque ça vient du nucléaire
et ça je pense que la commission
européenne doit enfin de comprendre
sinon on restera éternellement les
idiots du village global
vous êtes confiant dans la capacité de
l'europe à comprendre justement cette
cet enjeu et pour lequel est évidemment
l'europe est tout à fait bien placé en
fait ce que je crois c'est que bien sûr
qu'il ya des divergences en europe et
que ce qui l'empêchent d'avancer c'est
l'unanimité
la règle de l'unanimité je prends
l'exemple de la taxe gaffard les
entreprises sont pour les ménages sont
pour les opinions publiques sont en
cours sur 27 états membres vous en aviez
24 qui étaient pour et notamment
l'irlande qui est comme vous le savez
pratiques en cette matière là une
politique très en faveur des gars faé
qui a des liens très privilégié avec
google notamment l'irlande a notamment
bloqué cette initiative là donc moi ce
que je souhaite pas si un référendum ils
devaient de savoir ce que j'ai ce que je
souhaiterais c'est une proposition nous
la france un traité de souveraineté
écologique
l'allemagne la france le royaume-uni
bien qu'ils aient quitté l'union
européenne pour se mettre d'accord sur
un certain nombre de principes de
convergence fiscale de protection
économique et de grands investissements
écologiques et si on fait ça à trois si
vous voulez que les polonais soient
contre que les hongrois soit contre que
je ne sais quelle nation au col irlande
soit contre une certaine façon ils font
cavalier seul mais on peut pas nous
interdire d'avancé parce que sur 27
états membres y en a un deux ou trois
qui nous en empêche
donc il faut sortir du piège de
l'unanimité je crois que c'est ça la la
voie celle qu'on vient la règle de la
majorité souvent difficile à appliquer
en europe alors je veux je voudrais vous
amener maintenant sur un problème de
politique française faux si le
référendum ait lieu ça sera l'article 89
de la constitution qui oblige que les
deux assemblées vote en termes
identiques le texte le bon les députés
vont le faire évidemment la balle est
plutôt dans le camp du sénat lé sénat et
d une majorité de droite
est ce qu'à votre avis ils ont intérêt à
aller jusqu'au référendum où est-ce
qu'ils doivent jouer de la politique
politicienne en s'opposant au président
aux places moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
que le sénat propose un autre référendum
c'est à dire valide le principe du
référendum mehdi sbaa écouter on va
proposer deux questions en français la
première question c'est celle de la
révision des règles de concurrence dans
le traité sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne autorisait les aides
des temps naître en pose les règles sur
les positions dominantes des entreprises
nous on a des services publics superbe
des entreprises extrêmement compétitive
qui de fait sont toutes en position
dominante sur le marché français et donc
elles sont forcément défavorisés par
rapport à un régime allemand beaucoup
plus basé sur les hôtels et les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire donc
je dirais qu'il ya une première question
qui est celle dans et il y à la deuxième
sur le protectionnisme écologique et
sociale donc s'il sénat disait écouter
on va pas faire un référent on va en
faire pour vraiment changer les choses
là ça pourrait avoir du panache bon cela
étant
parler de politique politicienne c'est
vrai que l'initiative est prise par
emmanuel macron bien sûr pour se sortir
de cet échange compliquée avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat bien
sûr qu'il met la droite française dans
une situation difficile parce qu'elle
est elle et elle veut pas avoir l'air
anti écologique elle doit dire oui et
ainsi elle ne veut pas avoir l'air macro
ni stades modernes ont donc elle elle se
trouve mise dans une aporie de manière
un peu trop flagrante à mon avis pour
que ça puisse prospérer
d'ailleurs les français l'ont bien
compris qui sera à la fois pour le voter
oui pour le gouverneur d'hommes mais qui
voit aussi un coût politique
merci merci infiniment arthur de haine
alors je renvoie aussi à la tribune que
vous avez publié dans marianne sur le
site de marianne
et puis je rappelle le voilà vous êtes
élu d'une magnifique ville des yvelines
qui est maisons laffitte merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]